the field of genetics is rich with
discovery and innovation mapping the
human genome conducting genetic testing
and identifying new vaccines are just a
few ways this field has revolutionized
the way medicine is practiced many of
these developments were made right here
at Stanford every day our researchers
are advancing frontiers in biomedicine
and the biological sciences the Stanford
genetics and genomics certificate
program was created to help
professionals understand the latest
trends and technology using personalized
medicine and genetics research it's
offered entirely online we are able to
reach a community of learners and enable
them to apply their education
immediately in their own work is through
this cutting-edge research and approach
that the field will continue to advance
and the expertise of Stanford faculty
and top industry leaders can be utilized
for greater lasting impact from
technology leaders to medical sales
representatives to anyone interested in
biology and human health this program
will help you understand the big picture
behind genetics and give your career the
competitive edge with in a rapidly
changing industry
you